La Unión Europea es el WINDOWS de la política.
Es lenta, no funciona del todo bien y de vez
en cuando se bloquea. Sin embargo, seamos
honestos, el resto de alternativas no son
mucho mejores y cuestan mucho más.
A principios de este año, en VisualPolitik
sacábamos un vídeo hablando del auge de
la extrema derecha europea, que en aquel momento parecía
imparable. Y muchos analistas aseguraban que
el Brexit marcaba el principio del fin de
la Unión Europea.
Durante estos últimos
meses, todos los medios de comunicación se han llenado de trabalenguas como FREXIT,
NEEXIT o CZEXIT entre otros.
Sin embargo, este furor euroescéptico ha
durado bastante poco. Francia acaba de elegir
un nuevo presidente, Emmanuel Macron, que
defiende la Unión Europea a capa y espada.
Lo mismo ha ocurrido en el resto de países
que han tenido elecciones.
En otras palabras, que la Unión Europea está
más viva que nunca. Al menos durante los
próximos cuatro años.
Pero esperad un momento porque las cosas
son más complejas! En realidad, no todos
los europeístas son iguales ni comparten
la misma idea de cómo debería ser Europa y hacia donde debería avanzar.
Por ejemplo, Emmanuel Macron defiende una unión fiscal,
con impuestos muy parecidos en todos los países
miembros. Esta idea no les hace mucha gracia
ni a Jean Claude Juncker ni a Ángela Merkel.
Por otro lado, el ex primer ministro de Bélgica,
Guy Verhofstadt, que ahora mismo es el presidente
del Partido Liberal europeo, defiende un
un modelo de Unión Europea Federal,
al estilo de Estados Unidos.
Y os preguntareis, ¿Están de acuerdo
todos los europeístas con este político?
Pues lo cierto es que no. Lo único que comparten
todos estos políticos europeístas es que la Unión
Europea es buena pero ¿Qué es la Unión
Europea? Y en qué debería convertirse?
¿Se trata de una federación o de una Confederación?
¿Cuáles son los distintos modelos que
hay sobre la mesa? Hoy vamos a responder a
estas preguntas, pero antes vamos a ver un poco de  historia.
Margaret Thatcher es algo así como el Elvis
Presley de los euroescépticos. Durante décadas,
esta mujer, que fue primera ministra de Reino Unido a durante los años 80, ha sido la
gran inspiradora de muchos de esos movimientos
que quieren acabar con el proyecto europeo.
Pero nuevamente, la realidad es mucho más
complicada. Sí, es cierto que Margaret Thatcher
fue muy crítica todos estos procesos de
integración europea. En aquella época,
la Unión Europea no existíaa como tal.
Sólo era una comunidad de países que compartían
regulaciones y comerciaban libremente entre
ellos.
Sin embargo, en los años 80, los
gobiernos de los distintos países de la
zona se ponen de acuerdo para profundizar
más en esta unión. Es en esta época
cuando se habla de crear una moneda única
y una serie de nuevas instituciones, que luego en 1992 cristalizarían en lo que se conoce
cómo los  ACUERDOS DE MAASTRICH.
Pero, ¿qué pensaba Margaret Thatcher de todo
esto? Lo cierto es que si nos alejamos de
los estereotipos históricos y nos leemos
sus memorias, encontraremos citas como esta.
Reino Unido no sueña con una cómoda
y aislada existencia al margen de la Comunidad
Europea. Nuestro destino es en Europa, como
parte de la Comunidad.
¡Ojo! Esto no significa que Thatcher estuviera
de acuerdo con todos los políticos europeos.
Simplemente, que frente a otros que
querían unos Estados Unidos de Europa, con
capital en Bruselas en lugar de Washington,
ella defendía un modelo distinto. Un modelo
CONFEDERADO.
Por supuesto, queremos ver una Europa más
unida y con un mayor sentido de propósito
compartido. Pero debe ser de tal modo que
se preserven las distintas tradiciones, poderes
parlamentarios y orgullo nacional del país
de cada uno.
Pero antes de seguir, tenemos que explicar
cuál es la diferencia entre una Federación
y una Confederación. Un ejemplo de Federación
sería Estados Unidos. Texas y California
tienen sus propios parlamentos, sus propios
gobiernos y sus propias leyes totalmente distintas.
A día de hoy, la marihuana es legal en California
pero está prohibida en Texas. Sin embargo,
si el Congreso de Washington D.C. sacara una
ley legalizando el cannabis, automáticamente
quedarían abolidas todas las prohibiciones
en el resto de estados.
Sin embargo, en una confederación, los distintos
estados tienen muchísima más autonomía.
Ahora mismo, no hay ningún ejemplo puro
de confederacion en el mundo. Ni siquiera
Suiza. Es cierto que, en este país, los
cantones tienen mucha autonomía y hasta
impuestos distintos. Pero esperad un momento
porque eso no significa que sea una confederación!
Si, por ejemplo, en el parlamento de Berna
aprobaran una ley para legalizar la marihuana,
el resto de cantones deberían aceptarla automáticamente.
Si Suiza fuera de verdad una confederación,
cada una de esas asambleas cantonales deberían
hacer una votación donde decidirían si
quieren seguir prohibiendo el cannabis o no.
Es decir, que en contra de lo que dice mucha
gente, Suiza es una federación de libro.
Y ahora os preguntaréis ¿Qué es Europa?
¿Es una federación o una confederación?
Desde luego, no faltan aquellos que defienden
a capa y espada un modelo Federal. En los
últimos años, el gran defensor de esta
idea es el presidente del Partido Liberal,
Guy Verhofstadt.
Tenemos que reformar Europa. Convertirla
en una auténtica federación con capacidad
no solo en el campo económico sino también
para establecer una defensa, una capacidad
de investigación.
Pero vayamos a los hechos. A día de hoy
los
parlamentos nacionales tienen mucho más poder
que cualquier ley que venga de Bruselas.
Por ejemplo, hace años, los europarlamentarios
aprobaron una directiva que prohibía fumar
en los bares. Después, cada uno de los países
miembros tuvo que votar su propia ley nacional
antitabaco. ¿Y sabéis qué  pasó? Pues que en Austria
y en República Checa no se aprobaron tales leyes.
Y durante años, en los cafés de
Praga o Viena se podía fumar sin ningún
problema mientras que en Berlín o Madrid
estaba terminantemente prohibido.
Es más, incluso el IVA, que es el principal
impuesto que tenemos a nivel europeo, es distinto
en cada paés. En España pagamos un 21%
pero en Hungría llegan al 27% mientras que
en Alemania se quedan en un 19%.
En otras palabras, Europa se parece más
a Suiza que ha Estados Unidos.
Y, al igual
que decíamos con este otro país, tampoco
podemos decir que sea una confederación
pura y dura.
¿Por qué? Porque existen una serie de leyes que son de aplicación directa en Bruselas.
Es decir, que el euro-parlamento dicta el reglamento y los parlamentos nacionales no tienen que decir sí lo aceptan o no.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Está funcionando
este híbrido de "federación confederal"?
o ¿necesitamos unos Estados Unidos de Europa?
Todos hemos oído hablar de los muchos errores
que tiene esta integración europea. Pero
lo cierto es que muchos de estos fallos también
se podrían aplicar a cada uno de los estados
miembros. Por ejemplo, la crisis de los refugiados.
Es cierto que Bruselas ha sido incapaz de
sacar una política común para dar asilo
a todos los ciudadanos que huyen de países
como Siria, Irak o Libia. Pero no nos engañemos!
Sin ir más lejos, los políticos españoles
tampoco han sido capaces de ponerse de acuerdo
en su propio país.
Por un lado, el gobierno
nacional de Mariano Rajoy ha hecho todo lo posible para NO acoger a los refugiados. Sin
embargo, el ayuntamiento de Madrid ha hecho
todo lo contrario.
En otras palabras, no podemos esperar que
Bruselas solucione los problemas que siempre
han tenido los estados-nación. En política,
los trucos de magia no existen.
Pero esperad un momento porque esto no
significa que la Unión Europea sea perfecta!
En realidad sí que hay muchos problemas
propios de esta institución.
Por ejemplo, imaginad que sois un trabajador
autónomo y vivís en Hungría. Hacéis
un trabajo para una empresa que está en
Bélgica. Cuando les mandáis la factura,
tenéis que incluir el IVA o no?
La legislación
Europea dice que no, porque en los contratos
de servicios entre dos países comunitarios,
no hace falta incluir IVA. Pero cada país
tiene sus propias legislaciones tributarias,
que muchas veces contradicen las de Bruselas
Pero no sólo eso! ¿Qué tipo deberías
poner? ¿El que tienen en Hungría o el
de Bélgica? Todos estos problemas se podrían
resolver si hubiera unos principios comunes
en materia fiscal. Pero muchos estados no
quieren ceder su soberanía en este ámbito.
Y nadie se atreve a dar el paso hasta que
no estén todos de acuerdo. Con estas premisas,
es complicado poder tomar ninguna decisión política. Así que ahora os preguntareis:
¿Cuál puede ser la solución a este problema?
Las constituciones tienen una utilidad. Permiten
que todos los políticos y legisladores sepan
lo que no se puede hacer. Son como un acuerdo
de mínimos. De esta forma, un gobierno sabe
que puede sacar cualquier ley siempre y cuando
no viole la carta magna del país. Es un
sistema efectivo y se ha demostrado que funciona.
¿El problema? Que todos los intentos por
sacar una Constitución Europea han fracasado.
En 2005, tanto Francia como Países Bajos
celebraron sendos referéndums en los que
echaron por tierra la propuesta de Carta Magna
Europea. Años más tarde, los políticos
de Bruselas se volvieron a reunir para sacar
una versión renovada de este primer borrador,
lo que llamaron el Tratado de Lisboa.
En este caso, se trataba de una versión deslavada
de la Constitución. Pero la mayoría de
los problemas de integración persisten.
Lo cierto es que cada país tiene sus propios
intereses y es difícil ponerlos de acuerdo.
Así que, ¿Por qué no reconocer esas
diferencias? Desde la Comisión Europea han
sacado el llamado Libro Blanco de la Unión
Europea, donde se dibujan 5 posibles escenarios
de reforma. Uno de ellos permitiría que
cada estado acepte distintos niveles de integración.
Por otra parte, a principios de 2017, el semanario
The Economist proponía crear una Unión
Europea con distintos tipos de membresía.
Por un lado, tendríamos a los afiliados
Premium, que compartirían política fiscal,
moneda común y política exterior. Por
el otro, otros miembros de clase plateada
que sólo formarían parte del mercado común
y el espacio de libre circulación. Otros
miembros, vamos a llamarles de categoría
bronce sólo tendrían acceso a unas competencias
más limitadas. De esta forma, sería más
sencillo convencer a todos los países para
aprobar una Constitución Europea.
Por otra parte, la idea de unos Estados Unidos
de Europa ha perdido a muchos defensores.
Y las principales propuestas van más por
esta línea de Europa a distintas velocidades.
Mientras tanto, en Reino Unido ya están empezando
a hacer sus planes económicos tras el Brexit
¿Podrán llegar a hacer una unión comercial
con Estados Unidos? Haced click en este vídeo
para saberlo.
Y  ahora la pregunta es
¿Creéis que puede funcionar este híbrido
de confederación federal, con distintas
categoríaas de miembro? ¿O sería mejor
continuar intentando una federación donde
todos los países miembros tengan las mismas
reglas? Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta
en los comentarios.
Y por cierto! Tenemos que darle las gracias
al Profesor Óscar Sánchez, experto en
Derecho Constitucional en la Universidad de
Valladolid, que nos ha asesorado para preparar
este védeo.
Y por supuesto, No olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribíos al canal para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este védeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta
pronto.